avec nous donc dans l'entretien ce soir
caroline fourest bienvenue vous êtes
journaliste essayiste réalisatrice
éditorialiste à marianne vous êtes
l'auteur de ce livre génération offensé
de la police de la culture à la police
de la pensée
je rappelle aussi le titre de votre film
soeurs d'armes sur le combat des femmes
kurdes en syrie disponible en vod
merci à vous d'avoir accepté cette
invitation d'abord la situation aux
états unis on va rester quelques minutes
sur cette situation bien particulière
ce meurtre raciste d'un policier
américain n'est évidemment pas le
premier et à chaque fois j'ai envie de
dire il ya comme un sursaut comme une
envie d'un électrochoc qui changent les
choses
barack obama lui même a salué cette nuit
je le cite un changement de mentalité
qui pourrait déboucher sur des réformes
nationales
vous le sentez vous aussi ce tournant où
vous vous dites que c'est un événement
de plus qui finalement ne changera pas
grand chose
non je pense que le choc et mondial on
voit l'ampleur des manifestations
partout et ce qui change beaucoup les
choses c'est qu'on a des vidéos
désormais c'est qu'on a beaucoup on sait
qu'on installe des caméras sur les
policiers mais ça ne marche pas toujours
il est déclenché pas toujours on voit
pas toujours leur matricule
mais la réalité c'est que de plus en
plus tous les citoyens ont une caméra et
que donc ça change la donne parce que
quand on voit ce qu'on a vu en direct
avec just floyd l'ambiguïté n'est pas
possible l'abus d'autorité la violence
de ceux du regard de ce policier blanc
qui se sait filmer et qui pense quand
même qu'il a le droit d'aller jusque là
pendant huit minutes 45 secondes sur le
coup de john floyd c'est c'est quelque
chose qui bien sûr qu'il faut que la
justice passe parce que la justice va
elle nous apprendre que tu es très chaud
sur ce qui se passe avant ce qui se
passe après mais nous avons tous les
moyens de juger la disproportion la
violence les déshumanisation qui a coûté
la mort de georges floyd donc ça c'est
ça qui change la donne après ce qui est
difficile aux etats-unis c'est que c'est
un immense pays fédéral que chaque état
un peu sa police et sa politique et que
ce qui a été fait notamment sous barack
obama et hu avant peut-être on le voit
très vite des faits parce que là
aujourd'hui à la tête des états unis on
a quelqu'un qui a libéré tous les démons
qui a ravivé réellement 7,7 ce clivage
sur la question ethnique qui a toujours
empoisonné le pacte
américain mais lui donald trump a
carrément un discours qui flatte et qui
libère le pire de l'idéologie blanche
suprémacistes d'ailleurs chaque fois
qu'il ya un dérapage chaque fois qu'il
ya un groupe extrémiste blanc qui commet
un crime ou des drames qui se comporte
de façon hallucinante il trouve que
c'était plutôt des bons gars c'est son
expression
donc quelque part l'impunité qu'on a vu
chez ce policier c'est aussi ça c'est le
climat qu'un style le président actuel
des états unis c'est ce que j'allais
vous dirai ce que c'est aussi le
résultat de trois ans et demi de donald
trump est est ce que cette cette fierté
cette assurance du policier vient du
fait qu'ils se sont peut-être légitimé
par le par son propre président quoi
alors évidemment ça n'est pas né avec
donald trump cesser ces violences
racistes policière existe depuis des
années des années des années aux états
unis depuis toujours en réalité puisque
le pays s'est fait sur la ségrégation
il s'est fait sur la violence évidemment
sur les amérindiens puis sur la
ségrégation donc défaire ce poison la
prends des siècles mais en plus il faut
bien avouer que ce qui complique la
situation c'est que c'est un pays où la
circulation des armes est tellement
forte à peu près 300 millions d'armes à
feu pour un peu plus de 300 millions
d'habitants
ça veut dire qu'on a une police qui
contrairement peut-être à la nôtre a
toujours peur de se retrouver face un
suspect armé et d'ailleurs sur les 1000
personnes que tu es la police l'immense
majorité est armé mais dans la minorité
qui n'est pas armé
il ya une surreprésentation des
afro-américains et on est arrivé a
tellement tellement tellement de
dérapage de policiers américains qui
tire parce qu'il ya aussi cette culture
de jeu dégaine cette culture qui vient
là aussi de la culture américaine je
dégaine puis je réfléchis après il ya
tellement eu de morts par balles ou par
plaquage ventrale comme ce qui a tué de
georges floyd que être noire aux etats
unis aujourd'hui c'est quand vous êtes
interpellé il ya des très beaux films
qui ont été faits là dessus quand vous
êtes interpellé simplement vous vous les
enlevez votre ceinture de sécurité ou
prendre votre papier vos papiers dans la
boîte de votre voiture peut vous coûter
la vie et donc ça crée une relation
impossible impossible entre policiers et
citoyens et ce crime raciste aux états
unis a trouvé un écho réelle et sincère
dans la famille d'adama traoré et
provoqué des manifestations en france
contre les méthodes policières
violente potentiellement raciste là
aussi on en est aujourd'hui à se poser
des vraies questions sur un supposé
racisme au sein de notre propre police
ou d'un éventuel déni sur un racisme qui
serait là aussi peut-être structurels en
france je vais vous demander votre avis
dans un instant mais je voudrais qu'on
écoute d'abord sur ce point précis le
président du groupe plr au sénat bruno
retailleau qui était interrogé par notre
consoeur tam trang on l'écouté je vous
fait réagir après qu'une famille ressent
douloureusement la perte de l'un des
siens je le comprends parfaitement mais
une souffrance ne peut pas être là aussi
retourner contre la société
on ne peut pas faire d' équivalent entre
ce qui s'est passé aux états unis et ce
qui s'est passé en france
ces violences certains dans les deux
salles dont certains cherchent à
utiliser le drame des états unis pour
leur tournée contre la république et
surtout contre nos policiers et nos
gendarmes contre celles et ceux qui ont
pour fonction d'être le bouclier en
réalité des français et je pense qu'il
faut se méfier d'un modèle américain qui
est le modèle communautarisme
le modèle communautariste c'est celui
qui racialise qui renvoie chacun à sa
race à ses origines à sa religion nous
c'est le modèle républicain
on est français pas parce qu'on a une
couleur de peau particulière pas parce
qu'on professe une religion qui appuyait
blême là en france d'un rally for good
mais bien sûr mais mais ne disons pas
que les gendarmes ou les policiers sont
rangés ces deux corps sont rangés par le
racisme c'est absolument faux penser que
la justice française laisserait passer
de tels actes c'est aussi mal connaître
la justice française donc gardons raison
et je vois bien que derrière cela il ya
ceux qui veulent organiser la
convergence des luttes
on l'a déjà vu au moment dé gilet jaune
y compris avec ceux et celles qui
prétendent soutenir cette cause en
détournant justement cette mort
vraisemblablement accidentelle donc je
pense que c'est inacceptable et ça ne
peut être que des ferments de violences
en france donc je crois qu'il faut
raison garder il faut prendre du recul
de la hauteur alors beaucoup de choses
sont dites dans cette interview d'abord
floyd traoré aucun parallèle possible
selon vous alors d'abord je comprends
que le parallèle soit fait je comprends
qu'il soit en temps et je suis persuadé
que dans les traits
breux français qui sont allés manifester
il y avait un élan très sincère je suis
aussi assez convaincu que peu
connaissent les détails de la sphère
adama traoré ce qui est comparable c'est
que dans les deux cas il y a une méthode
d'interpellations qui est en discussion
on ne sait pas encore il ya des
expertises il ya des contre expertises
et bien malin celui qui prétend à la
place de la justice savoir la vérité
c'est quand même un peu comme le débat
sur l'hydraulique leur quine faut avoir
un peu de modestie et accepter aussi que
des experts puissent faire leur travail
c'est pour ça que c'est long aussi bien
sûr que c'est trop long mais la justice
elle a besoin de temps pour établir une
vérité et l enquête à charge et à
décharge et donc c'est la justice qui
pourrait établir si adama traoré a été
victime d'un plaquage ventrale qui est
responsable de sa mort ce qui est
certain c'est que il ya aussi une
différence avec la sphère floyd parce
que ça n'a pas été filmé la sphère
fleuve nous sommes tous capables avec la
vidéo que nous avons d'établir et de
voir par nos yeux que ce plaquage c'est
au-delà du placage c'est un genou qui
est enfoncée sur sa sur sa gorge dure
huit minutes 45 secondes et nous pouvons
voir de nos yeux que josh block n'a
opposé aucune résistance il n'a pas fui
oui il n'a pas bougé là le policier qui
l'a il est même d'une incroyable dignité
d'un incroyable calme alors qu'il est en
train de s'éteindre de mouret en croire
la third adama traoré assa traoré il
aurait prononcé les mêmes mots je ne
peux pas respirer
lui aussi il a dit ça c'est possible
qu'il ait prononcé les mêmes goûts alors
ni sa soeur ni sa famille ni nous par le
biais d'une vidéo n'étions là c'est bien
pour ça que je comprends l'émotion d'une
soeur et je comprends l'émotion de toute
une famille mais l'émotion n'est pas la
justice est en tout cas ça n'est pas
très juste pour just floyd de laisser
croire que son altercation brutale est
le fruit d'une un délit de fuite ou
d'une volonté de bousculer les policiers
que les interpellés dans le cas de flop
nous savons que ce n'est pas le cas donc
même si on peut estimer que cette
émotion sincère pour la fair floyd doit
nous permettre au regard du nombre de
morts il n'y a pas que damas traoré
cédric joue via plus récemment est plein
et plusieurs autres cas pas aussi
nombreux qu'aux états unis c'est
incomparable nombre de cas mais
néanmoins on sait que le plaquage entre
hal et dangereux parce que un policier
peut se
se représenter un grand gaillard et
penser qu'il est très costaud et que
donc il peut appuyer très fort et en
réalité cette personne peut soit avoir
des fragilités soit ne pas en avoir mais
dans tous les cas on ne peut pas le
savoir donc cette pratique est
dangereuse c'est pour ça que je pense
qu'on devrait s'unir pour essayer de
faire un débat constructif qui débouche
sur des solutions qui puissent sauver
des vies ça ça veut dire s'unir contre
cette méthode mais elle n'est pas du
tout le cas et qu au contraire peut-être
êtes-vous d'accord avec bruno retailleau
que certains essayent d'instrumentaliser
l'affairé floyd pour finalement
racialisée le débat aussi en france vous
l'observez vous le constatez vous êtes
d'accord avec cette idée je suis pas
souvent d'accord avec bruno retailleau
mais comme je travaille mais là mais
comme je travaille depuis
malheureusement déjà quelques années sur
les mouvements identitaires elle soit
d'extrême droite racistes ou qu'ils
soient d'une gauche qui veut
effectivement racialisée tous les débats
pas pour trouver des solutions
pas pour faire reculer les
discriminations son objectif est de
vivre moi je les appelle des profiteurs
de guerre identitaire sont des gens qui
vivent du chaos qui vivent de la
victimisation et qui ne veulent jamais
qu'on avance ensemble et je remarque oui
malheureusement dans ce dossier très
vite les mots qu'il instille les
parallèles qu'ils font la façon dont ils
trompent le grand public sur la
situation française fait que ce sera
très facile pour ceux qui ne veulent pas
bouger qui ne veulent pas réformé qui ne
veulent pas par exemple poser la
question de l'interdiction de ce
plaquage ventrale d'y résister parce que
quand vous salissez la cause c'est
toujours plus facile de l'ignorer donc
pour vous ils le font en conscience ils
le font pour manipuler à des fins
politiciennes purement politiciennes à
il ya des militants politiques dans
cette affaire qui ya les deux vous
auriez bien qu'il ya des gens qui sont
touchés par un deuil personnel et qui
sont dans une émotion qui a suscité une
rage qui devient très politique qui
emploie un vocabulaire très politique
mais j'ai aussi connu des proches après
l'attentât de charlie les familles
n'étaient pas toujours dans le
discernement c'est normal quand on a une
telle douleur au passage pour que les
gens sachent la justice est longue pour
tout le monde
par exemple les assassins de charlie
hebdo le procès des assassins charlie
hebdo n'est toujours pas venu devant la
justice ça le rythme actuel de notre
justice et c'est pour tout le monde
mais dans les deux cas dans les deux cas
dans tous les cas on ne peut pas
remplacer la justice par l'émotion et
donc ce qui m'ennuie c'est
qu'aujourd'hui les gens qu'on ne peut
pas avoir la hâte en trois ans de se
faire une opinion sur une idée
intervenir dans le débat public on a
tendance
jugés en fonction de nos préjugés ou nos
grilles de lecture a priori donc il ya
des gens qui vont voir juste la couleur
du policier la couleur de la personne
qui est décédée qui vont en déduire
forcément que c'est un cas racistes
alors que peut-être pas et des fois
peut-être que oui parce que pour finir
la seule chose c'est que je ne veux pas
que ce débat nous occulte le fait que
bien sûr qu'il ya un problème de racisme
dans la police et évidemment c'est ce
que j'ai à lui dire parce que on est ce
qu'il n'ya pas aussi une forme de déni
quand on dit mais absolument pas les
gendarmes les policiers ne sont pas du
tout raciste la france n'est pas raciste
on est le pays des droits de l'homme on
a du mal à envisager que peut-être on
est un problème avec le racisme
et ce qui est du déni d'après vous il ya
du denim est évidemment que il y à une
montée d'insulter le délit de faciès a
toujours existé c'est pas nouveau il ya
on va pas dire les choses comme on va
pas à s'inventer un monde idéal dans le
passé mais avec la fatigue des forces de
l'ordre et aussi avec le climat les
attentats ce qui s'est passé ensuite je
pense qu'un vocabulaire s'est libéré et
qu'on assiste parce que d'abord on a
aussi des vidéos qui nous font voir des
scènes qui sont extrêmement choquant de
la part de gens qui portent l'uniforme
qui représente la république qui
représente la nation qui d'abord créer
un climat détestable pour leurs
collègues qui ne sont leurs collègues
non blancs et qui vivent avec cette
sociabilité où le vocabulaire raciste et
décomplexée et ensuite quand il ya un
cas limite un cas sensible quelqu'un qui
résiste un peu moins cas où les forces
de l'ordre sont tellement fatigués
qu'ils ils ont dû ils ont peu de temps
pour réfléchir avant d'agir
eh bien ce sera 6 me décomplexer
favorise des passages à l'acte qui sont
insupportables et qui en plus je veux
dire vraiment porte porte tort à
l'ensemble du pays parce que quand vous
du millier un citoyen en raison de kiel
et que vous n'arrivez plus à faire la
différence entre des signaux qui sont
ceux de quelqu'un qui a un comportement
pas très civique et des signaux que vous
finissez par associer systématiquement à
toute personne qui a la même couleur
vous sortez la personne que vous avez
mal traité de la citoyenneté vous le
pousser à se radicaliser et vous lui
donnez envie de se radicaliser donc vous
faciliter le travail de propagande de
gens qui vont passer derrière
alors soit dans sa version extrême
gauche identitaire soit dans sa version
carrément intégristes donc pour les
policiers eux mêmes pour leur faciliter
la tâche
il faut absolument arrêter de nier qu'il
est temps d'ouvrir ce chantier de ré
ouvrir ce chantier
ce qui est fou c'est que cette affaire
floyd et ce nouvel élan de la part de la
famille du comité de soutien damas
traoré arrive quelques semaines quelques
jours après laffaire j'allais dire la
sphère camélia jordana qui a joué dans
le film que vous avez tourné soeurs
d'armes et qui avait dit sur le plateau
de france 2 je vais juste répéter ces
mots je parle des hommes et des femmes
qui vont travailler tous les matins en
banlieue qui se font massacrer pour
nulle autre raison que leur couleur de
peau
elle avait peut-être été très loin dans
ses propos mais ce soir là elle a dit
quelque chose qui trouve un écho
finalement aujourd'hui on est quand même
dans cette période où on a tout d'un
coup cette jeunesse métissé identité
visible qui dit attention nous on a peur
des flics et elle a parlé de massacre
carrément comment vous voyez cela on est
dans une période complexe sûr je crois
qu'on les en permanence mais c'est vrai
que ça s'arrange pas dans le cas des
propos de camélia jordana évidemment que
je connais on a tourné ensemble on
s'apprécie mais il ya plusieurs choses
d'abord quand elle parle de son ressenti
quant à camélia jordana qui est une
comédienne est une chanteuse connue et
aimée dans ce pays vous dit qu'elle a
peur de la police
je pense que personne ne doit lui nier
son ressenti en doit l'entendre parce
que justement venant de quelqu'un comme
camélia jordana ça veut dire quelque
chose de la dégradation du climat
quand elle dit que des gens sont
massacrés tous les jours pour leur
couleur de peau par la police je suis
dit oria liste je suis pas chanteuse je
suis pas comédienne je suis obligé
d'être attaché à la précision des mots
massacre et sous-entend que quelqu'un se
fait tuer que quelqu'un se fait au
minimum massacre et physiquement ça
n'est pas le cas des statistiques ce
n'est pas la réalité qui remonte même
des associations dénonçant les bavures
policières
il faut remettre les choses en
perspective nous ne sommes quand même
pas déjà aux états unis il faut s'en
réjouir
au lieu de tout le temps voir le monde
plus violent qu'il n'est pas ce qu'ils
font il faudrait pas y aller il ya mille
personnes tuées par la police aux états
unis nous en sommes à 10 ou 20 par an
c'est évidemment déjà trop et c'est
incomparable
et le délit de faciès est une réalité
alors camélia et du sud de la france
mais aussi on a à peu près de la même
région c'est vrai qu'on a tendance
parfois exagéré mais encore une fois
l'éditorialiste que je suis cette
surprend dédire massacre et ça
correspond pas quotidiennement pour sa
couleur de peau c'est plus complexe que
ça il ya aussi des comportements les
incivilités qui font que les policiers
qui ont accumulé je sais pas combien
d'heures supplémentaires mal payés
depuis les attentats qui ont eu peur de
se faire tuer parce qu'il ya aussi aussi
plus de 20 policiers par an qui se font
tuer parce que policiers et depuis des
attentats c'est pire c'est terrible donc
ils sont dans un état tel état de
fatigue les gilet jaune la violence des
protestations toute protestation à
laquelle nous assistons en ce moment ça
épuise les forces de l'ordre donc ça ne
les aide pas à avoir le dit c'est
rayonnant sentiment est une parole anti
flics dont nous avons tous besoin
il ya les deux en réalité c'est à dire
que j'ai l'impression qu'on essaie
d'encourager une jeunesse a
effectivement avoir peur de la police et
en même temps on a une police qui se
sont tellement applaudi par le reste de
la population depuis les attentats
qu'elle se déshonore parfois en toute
impunité et qu'elle pense qu'elle peut
aller plus loin et j'ai envie dit il
faut qu'on sorte de cette ce double
fantasme de cette double exagération oui
il y à un délit de faciès
oui la police comme et des
interpellations de façon brutale à des
propos qui sont intolérables et ça
dérape parfois et non c'est pas parce
qu'elle nous protège la plupart du temps
et pas parce que le monde est de plus en
plus violents et que c'est de plus en
plus difficile pour eux qu'on doit le
tolérer on doit peut-être mieux les
payer comme les soignons on doit
peut-être leur permet d'avoir plus de
temps de repos mais sûrement pas
pardonné le racisme dans votre livre
dont je rappelle le titre génération
offensé de la police de la culture à la
police de la pensée vous parlez d'un
antiracisme identitaire qui menacerait
la liberté de création et la liberté
d'expression est ce que vous pouvez nous
expliquer pourquoi et précisément mais
il ya ça fait longtemps qu'une bataille
entre deux antiracisme peut-être que
elle existait déjà du temps de martin
luther king mais et malcom x sauf qu'à
l'époque il était face à une adversité
tellement violente sur le racisme à
l'époque était pour le coup totalement
institutionnels et donc ses nuances
n'était pas aussi grave aujourd'hui nous
sommes dans un contexte où réellement
des gens se revendiquent de
l'antiracisme pour assigner les gens en
fonction de leur couleur de peau de leur
identité est tracé
au fond une sorte de ligne où il ya d'un
côté ceux qui ont droit de parler et de
créer ce qu'ils n'ont pas le droit
donc finalement raciste aussi oui pour
moi enfin moi qui viens d'un antiracisme
universaliste ou au contraire on a tous
travaillé pour essayer de déconstruire
ces mécanismes visant à signer les êtres
à leur couleur de peau ou alors prêté
des propos ou des comportements en
raison de leur couleur de peau c'est
extrêmement choquant mais je remarque
que celle de l'est de moins en moins
pour la génération qui vient et que
cette génération là pensent en termes de
tribus pense en terme d'identité
un peu comme sur les réseaux sociaux et
se dit bah oui les blancs ont droit de
faire ça les laisser comme la notion de
privilège blanc qui est en train d'être
mis dans le débat public je pense qu'on
en a pour vingt ans à se tromper de
combat avec un terme pareil parce que on
va plus parler de discrimination raciste
on va parler de privilèges blanc donc
qu'est-ce que ça amène comme conséquence
camus disait mal nommer les choses c'est
ajouter au malheur du monde je peux vous
dire que là on est en plein dedans
si on en est à compter qui doit
s'excuser d'être né blanc
la seule conséquence de ça c'est que
vous allez conforter les gens qui ont
déjà l'impression l'est par exemple
toutes les classes moyennes qui sont en
train de tomber vous imaginez ce
qu'elles vont tomber après la crise
économique qui vient qui on a déjà vu à
l'oeuvre au moment des faits les jaunes
qui va commencer à se dire ah bon moi je
suis blanc je suis pauvre je fais finit
pas mes fins de mois
j'ai peur pour mes gosses et pour les
nourrir et je dois m'excuser des
privilégiés c'est ça qui a fait le vote
trump aux états unis et moi tout mon
inquiétude et c'est le coeur de
génération france et c'est qu'on n'est
pas un donald trump peut-être ici ce
sera eric zemmour mais pour moi c'est à
peu près équivalent en terme de danger
pour un pays je ne veux pas qu'on pousse
je travaille sur l'extrême droite
justement qu'on donne ce carburant pour
la prépa mais avait l'intimé alexandra
quoi il en était arrivé là pourquoi en
sont ils arrivés à à ce point
revendiquer une identité
peut-être même à essayer d'effacer celle
des autres et celle des blancs en
parlant de privilèges pourquoi en sont
ils arrivés là est-ce que c'est aussi
parce que pendant peut-être quelques
années plusieurs années on a essayé de
gommer les identités peut-être parce
qu'on a eu ou voulu je me fais l'avocat
dit non non c'est certain qu'il ya eu
une forme de laïcité d'un
de laïcisme forcené qui a voulu gougaud
mais les origines les identités les et
les couleurs etc aujourd'hui 10 bat stop
nous on veut aussi rôle indiqué voilà ce
mélange en bateau là aussi ne mélangeons
pas le débat sur la laïcité le débat sur
l'égalité le sait le débat c'est de
savoir si l'universalisme a été trop
normatif on n'a pas pris assez en compte
les discriminations ce qui a radicalisé
les revendications je peux vous dire que
je viens du combat lgbt et que quand
j'étais présidente du centre gay et
lesbien et qu'on se battait pour le pacs
en 1998 et très peu de lesbiennes sur le
plateau de télévision à l'époque et on
est et on parlait de nous comme des
animaux à l'assemblée nationale à
l'époque nous étions victimes pour le
coup réellement d'une discrimination
d'état ce qui n'est pas le cas il n'y a
pas dans il n'y a pas dans la
constitution dans la loi française
quelque chose qui dit que les noirs ou
que les personnes non blanches ont moins
de droits que les autres
il y avait du temps j'étais militante
dans ces associations dans la loi
quelque chose qui interdisait aux
homosexuels de fonder une famille de se
marier de faire reconnaître leurs
enfants donc il y avait une
discrimination d'état
et pourtant malgré ce contexte malgré
des gens qui nous traitaient comme des
animaux qui estimé que nous allions
violé des enfants
si nous avions sept cette possibilité là
j'ai toujours pensé et je pense que
c'est le cas dans mouvement des droits
civiques aussi qu'il ya toujours eu
cette voie là qu'on pouvait s'en sortir
par la dignité par la patience par
l'exemplarité et qu'on devait tracer un
chemin qui mène vers l'universel parce
que c'était le seul moyen de convaincre
tout le monde et pas par le combat anti
hétéro disons mais comme tout ce qui est
peut-être en train de se passer si je
disais si je disais même un sdf devrait
s'excuser d'avoir des trains d'avoir un
privilège et eros sincèrement je suis
désolé je ne vois pas qui jarry j'irai
convaincre qu'il faut se battre ensemble
contre l'homophobie
je trouve ça ridicule je trouve ça
absurde je trouve ça con tre performant
et donc je mets la même réflexion sur
l'ensemble des luttes pour l'égalité
contre les discriminations je pense que
chaque fois qu'on perd patience et qu'on
quitte le chemin constructif décide de
dénoncer ensemble des discriminations on
s'enferme alors peut-être qu'on en vit
mieux peut-être que ça permet d'avoir
plus de médiatisation que ça permet
d'avoir son public les assauts sur
internet etc
ça crée des égéries certainement mais
pourquoi en serait-il arrivé là
pardonnez moi je ne sais pas si vous
avez répondu à cela comment comme est
d'après vous
vous dire je vais vous dire que j'ai pas
besoin trop d'intellect pour savoir
puisque je les ai ressenti physiquement
personnellement organiquement je sais
très bien ce qu'est la colère d'avoir le
sentiment d déshumanisé exclut la
citoyenneté dans le regard de l'autre
cette violence là et c'est pour ça que
je comprends très bien la violence du
délit de faciès
parce que je pense que chaque fois que
quelqu'un l'a ressenti dans le regard
d'un policier j'ai vu une vidéo sur un
médiateur qui a l'air d'être quelqu'un
qui est justement une force d'apaisement
qui a été appréhendée comme s'il était
un cambrioleur et qui une fois qu'il est
traîné dans un commissariat
le comédien jimmy toi je te reconnais je
te sais je connais d'habitude n'est pas
la regarder son casier qui était vierge
je connais tu fais toujours les mêmes
bêtises simplement parce qu'il s'est pas
dissocié un noir d'un autre noir et bien
la personne sort de ce commissariat ils
n'arrivent plus à être médiateur il n'a
plus la force des médiateurs et
probablement qu'il a un peu la rage et
que cette rage peut mener à la haine
chez aucun mal à comprendre ce trajet et
pourtant je pense que dans l'histoire
les minorités n'ont jamais gagné en
s'enfermant dans cet ept à ce qu'au
contraire la majorité conservatrice qui
ne veut rien changer se régale de voir
leur posture victimaire et je veux dire
se replie la facilite le repli
majoritaire et au final il faut pas se
tromper un c'est pas ce qu'ils vont
gagner qui sont majoritaires en matière
de repli identitaire
malheureusement c'est plus l'extrême
droite qu'autre chose et comment on
trouve un équilibre entre ce
multiculturalisme à l'américaine avec le
des communautés qui cohabitent qui
vivent les unes à côté des autres et ce
multiculturalisme en france aussi mais
qui a du mal à s'entendre quand on
trouve mais c'est tout le second modèle
c'est tout le débat entre justement une
approche universaliste et une approche
identitaire ça veut dire que l'universel
et ne doit pas être confondu avec le
normatif
il ne s'agit pas de nier il ne s'agit
pas de penser que tout va bien dans le
meilleur des mondes et d'imposer une
norme qui sous une forme un peu
traditionnelle revisitée l'universalisme
au contraire c'est de pointer du doigt
de nommer de nommer mentalement le
racisme parce que on parle de diversité
on a inventé plein de mots maintenant
par le privilège blanc mais tout ça
c'est des mots pour éviter de poser le
mot racisme quand on parle de racisme
discrimination c'est précis et ensuite
faut trouver des solutions mais des
solutions qui ne soient pas simplement
de s'excuser de pleurer ou de crier la
haine ou de demander à prendre les armes
par exemple parce que ça ça va pas nous
mener
vraiment
dans un chemin très constructif les
solutions c'est par exemple de dire
qu'écouter on voit bien que le plaquage
centrale est une pratique qui est
dangereuse mobilisons nous pour le
demander son interdiction
molly mobilisons-nous noir blanc de
toutes les couleurs parce que parce que
ça nous concerne tous ça n'est pas que
la sphère des noirs il ya d'ailleurs de
toutes les couleurs qui meurent sous ces
pratiques policières
le délit de faciès oui ça concerne
plutôt ceux qui sont victimes de racisme
mais pareil c'est celle affaire de tous
merci ce sera loin de la fin merci
infiniment caroline fourest d'avoir été
notre invité je rappelle le titre de ce
livre dont on a parlé pendant cet
entretien génération offensé de la
police de la culture à la police de la
pensée
et je rappelle soeurs d'armes qu'on peut
voir en vod votre tout premier film
après plusieurs dizaine de documentaires
merci en tout cas d'avoir été avec